how are you John Rich I'm doing great
how are you well it seems that I'm
better than Chris Paul's hamstring John
it's that it seems like there's a big
damper on that big game five victory
last night well first of all a lot of
people are shocked that of course the
Rockets could get this to this point
pull out these last two victories in
overtime including the previous win in
Oakland and there was tempered last
night because Paul got hurt and rich you
know we've been watching the hamstring
injuries for decades and and you know
this when he sat on the bench staring
into space while they were trying to
escape with the victory instead of being
up and cheerleading you knew it was bad
he's had hamstring issues he said soft
tissue injuries and so the fact watching
him as he was in the last minute made me
think he knows it's bad now we don't
know for sure of course I wouldn't take
him to Oakland I would leaving here
rehabbing 24/7 but just based on his
reaction I'll be stunned if he plays the
rest of this series I'm with you John
I'm with you there's no reason to get on
a plane there's no reason to go to
altitude there's no reason to get off
the plane and get on a bus and go
walking around I just you know I don't
know how you even get him ready for a
game seven I had the same reaction to
John when he's staring into space not
even reacting he's walking off the court
and everybody's jubilant and and it's
not because you know there's an eye on
Chris it's because he knows as an
all-world athlete that this this is so
bad that this might even count him out
for a game seven two and I don't mean to
be alarmist it is dead how would that
affect this team do you think I don't
think you're being alarmist I think
everybody here you know some people are
keeping their fingers crossed but the
fact is anybody paid attention knows
that there's danger these are going to
miss some time you know worst-case
scenario is is they win that and they
lose in Oakland they win here and then
they got to play the Cavs of the Celtics
and he can't play then then it would be
really bad Mike D'Antoni went to a
seven-man bench all season he had a deep
bench by Luke booth is not playing
because
he's got a shoulder injury he can't play
and I'm guessing Johnson's gonna have to
play he hasn't done much since April and
so they've got to have somebody step up
to specially James Harden it would help
if harden started shootin better and
they need him to step up and Paul has
stepped up for him thing is rich this
year when harden zone when he's not on
the floor Paul was when Paul went on the
floor he was now they had one of them on
the floor all the time unless it was a
blowout but I did see that statistic
that there +11 with just harden on the
floor in this series and now I don't
know how telling that stat is because I
don't know who was on the floor for the
Warriors when it was just harden on the
floor for the Rockets but that might be
something to hang your hat on and Eric
Gordon has just raised his game I mean
he is the guy who has realized along
with Paul but this is the moment and
raised his game to a certain level do
you think that perhaps he could step
into the for I mean that's the guy that
Dan Tony mentioned right off the bat
last night in his postgame comments is
he would be into the playmaker role
bridge everybody thought about Gordon
immediately you know he's been ever
since he got here he's been tremendous
off the bench he's had to make some
starts at times the Warriors bench
didn't do squat compared to Gordon so
yes he's the natural guy but when you're
in a seven-man rotation and you're
playing every other day is not like last
week where you get three game days off
between games which is what they would
really like to have now but the Warriors
Laws think we're dollars so they lost
Paul and others do have to step up I
think the Warriors will win this game
and they'll come back to us Ben and both
of these series I think of seven games
and that's great considering what we've
been watched and the NBA playoffs which
hasn't been all that exciting John
McClain here on the Rich Eisen show what
was it like when they they brought the
kids from the high school in Santa Fe
out there last night before they injured
you can imagine that has been a gloom
and doom hanging over the area ever
since 10 were killed including 8
students and two teachers and every team
is honoring them you know JJ Watts
paying for the funerals he went down
immediately see the kids
the hospital go to the school go to the
to the first responders and everybody
now the rockets Astros have honored
their but it's just it's it's uplifting
to see the ones who survived but you
just feel crushed because you think this
can't happen in my in my city everybody
says that and then when it doesn't hit
so close to home you just devastated
it seems that JJ has entered the realm
of Nolan Ryan Hakeem
all time Houston sports greats John is
that a fair assessment for this kid from
a gamble in there too there are three
big number 34 s and and why you know JJ
he's only played in like five games the
last two years six because of his
injuries and us but he hasn't the time
he hasn't been able to spend on the
field and on the practice field he's
spent helping people after Hurricane
Harvey now there's read something really
bothers me is when I see people don't
know him as they've never met him and
I've known him since the day he was
drafted in 2011 they think oh he's a
phony
there's nothing phony about JJ what he's
very sincere and a lot of times it's the
people that publicize the stuff not him
like I found out last Friday night at
10:30 what he done came didn't come from
him came from the person who were the
kid at the school and and people reacted
as you can imagine and he doesn't really
care about that he cares about the
community he told me a long time ago he
said when I am our prayer phrase
paraphrase what he said when I'm married
and got kids and I'm a coach somewhere
I'll I'll sit around and watch the Rich
Eisen show and but while I'm single I'm
gonna get out in the community and do
things for people
now take a little leeway with what he
said that sounds good enough in other
words as long as he's got the time he's
going to do things in the community
because later he's going to have
responsibilities with a wife and
children now the the the Liberty he took
was the coaching part right everything
else was really over paid him quote
verbatim quote okay very good
John McClain here in the Rich Eisen show
how has deshaun Watson looked I mean
just based on the video that I've seen
he looks good to go John think he'll be
a hundred percent started training camp
he'd be a hundred percent before that he
had to surgery first week of November
he's been out on the field with him for
six weeks we in the media just got to
see him this week everything Bill
O'Brien said he's going to do he did
they don't have him in Lebanon 11
because they don't want somebody
tripping and falling and rolling into
his knees wearing a brace on his right
knee the only good thing about this
injury is he blew out his left when in
college and had that surgery in January
and came back for the start of the
season led him to the national
championship so he knows how to rehab
but they want him out there throwing in
individual drills and 707 to his
teammates somebody said well who's
closest to him and practice I was at
Bill O'Brien hmm and in terms of Bob
McNair the owner there John how integral
was he in the in the new policy for the
national anthem that was announced a
couple of days ago everything I've read
and seen I'd not see Bob's name
mentioned anywhere I noticed I noticed
that but I know how he stands he's told
he's told people numerous times he wants
players standing in attention in the
national anthem and so I know him well
enough to know he's glad there's a
resolution even though a lot of people
disagree with it I know all the owners
are glad there's a resolution they had
to have known they're going to be is
going to be unmitigated criticism I
haven't seen anybody praising it and but
I know he's happy to just have a rule
now and I'm guessing most teams are not
going to say they don't have to till
preseason about what they're going to do
but if they're smart they'll do what
Christopher Johnson said and not find
their own players that'd be really bad
if you did know the teams didn't and
you're trying to sign free agents yeah I
don't you think that would be don't you
think that would affect matters I sure
do yeah I mean you know how they look at
things like state income taxes well if
an agents got a player he said that
owner fined five players last year he
wants you this owner didn't find any and
he wants and the money's about the same
players gonna say send me to the team
that the owner didn't do this so you
don't think the owners would take a
mulligan on this knowing what what has
happened
that there were just literally I guess
what seven players who were kneeling
we're doing some form of a demonstration
and both by the end of the season last
year this is now on the front pages and
at top story and news items Doug Baldwin
calling the president an idiot I mean
that's sort of discipline look it's it's
there's a lot of raw emotions that were
brought up in late May that really in
when you think about it didn't have to
be do you think there would be a
mulligan I think the rule is
preposterous I can't believe when you
have all these smart people that make
billions of dollars wouldn't understand
the possible fallout but the compromise
was not with players of course the
compromise was with the owners from the
hardliners to the ones who were more
tolerant and I think that's what they
did and it's gotten criticism and you
imagine every time every citizen
national anthem is over rich all the
photographers and videographers and TV
people are going to be pointed at the
area that comes out of the dressing room
to see who stayed in what if your home
team and your team's inside and all the
visitors are out there this is going to
be controversial all season long as long
as one player protests everybody would
like to have it like Titan chard
Matthews grew up a military family
marine family his form of protest was
stayed in the dressing room till as to
the national anthem and people respected
that John McLane Houston Chronicle sir
appreciate the time to juic of the
report that the mother of dragons Emilia
Clarke said she is shot her last scene
for the Game of Thrones series that's in
the can did you see what she had to say
I did not please I know she's your
favorite right the mother of dragons
[ __ ] right she said that the scene
after up is what she said that I'm
worried she's gonna die lotta gonna die
because it's the last season but she
also said that the stuff they're having
her do were as bizarre it made it seem
like she Brockman you told me to make it
seem like she was the last one standing
did you get that from it mmm no I did
not think that initially
you'll never be as good when she came
out of the fire original draft
originally masked me about her great
starting pitching staff here that's true
that's right I went right to Game of
Thrones but they I talked about the game
of Thrones any time now I know alright
so then you have the floor because I am
remiss and not asking you about you know
Charlie Morton looking as he did this
this staff as a er a with coal and
Verlander and Keuchel and McCullers less
than two and two point three I think
it's less than that right now your
thoughts on that jungle eyeball era
which since 1920 they've given up fewer
runs through 50 games than any team in
history and they're starting to hit they
weren't hitting for a while or the
record would be better they left so many
guys on base but right now they got four
legitimate candidates for the side Young
Award Keuchel can't be included in there
but they have just been phenomenal keep
an eye on Sunday's game Trevor Bauer
right Garrett called teammates enemies
they hate each other big front page
story but Bob Nightingale and USA Today
today about why they ate each other
they're gonna be playing in Cleveland I
can't wait why do they hate each other
very quick well they dragged down one of
his coaches thought it was a competitive
thing they're totally different guys
that was anonymous
an anonymous astro told Bob Nightingale
he thought it was that the word was it
was jealous Leon Bauer's part but he's
become a it's gonna be a great rivalry I
was just wish this game were here
because when Bauer created all that
controversy last month I told my wife go
by every Indians take it now that's
right he didn't pitch in the three games
that's right because he basically he's
accusing something of going on with the
Astros that's right John you take care
of all chatter thank you very much -
have a great week you bet that's John
McLean the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience